let's bring in national border patrol
council president brandon judd i just
want to read to you a tweet from
yesterday from the national border
patrol union saying joe biden is an
american nightmare a colossal failure
who has erased the rule of law made a
complete joke of our border and actively
works to encourage assist and reward
criminal acts american citizens and
legal immigrants are on to him
um
i i'm assuming that this the border
patrol agents who are working every
single day
they think no one's coming to help them
they are on their own and they have
absolutely just had it
yeah unfortunately dana we know that
when we put on that uniform we're just
not getting any support from this
administration when you see the total
numbers um that we're dealing with right
now it's it's astronomical that the
amount of resources that it takes to
deal with that those sizes of groups
takes all of our resources out of the
field which then creates gaps in our
coverage when you look at the numbers
that are coming across
we know that they're they're gaming the
system because they're coming through
mexico they're being offered visas work
visas but they're not staying in mexico
which our state department has certified
as a safe third country
if they're all if they're truly fleeing
from persecution if they're truly
fleeing because they they fear for their
lives they would stay in the first safe
third country that they come to but
instead they're coming to the united
states and that's what shows us that
this is all about economics and it's
because president biden continues to
release people into the united states
people are going to continue to come
he's rewarding them for for illegal acts
and that is what is the magnet that's
drawing all these people call for number
two is the southwest border
apprehensions per day approximately 7
802 people per day in april and even the
the department of homeland security said
that that could actually even go higher
of course we're waiting on uh the court
rulings on that
but yesterday tell me what happened here
so a federal judge threw out the biden
administration border policy that
limits who immigration authorities can
arrest and deport what does this mean
for your folks that are on the ground
well if he actually lets us do our job
that means an awful lot it will then
allow us to
send people back and when we when we
actually enforce a consequence for
violating our laws people stop coming
and that's the problem right now uh the
biden administration has completely and
totally gutted all enforcement and when
you gut enforcement then people continue
to come but the problem is is he can
still use
executive authority and say he doesn't
have the resources to actually um
take these people and and remove them to
the uh to another country the problem is
you cannot hold a president of the
united states in contempt of a judicial
ruling and so these rulings are great
because it brings attention to to the
public the public understands what's
going on but the administration can't be
held accountable for not following
through on a judge's order just talking
to bill in the commercial break i just
wonder why this
does not seem to command the attention
from the administration
that it obviously requires why do you
think that is
because the white house is filled with
activists if you look at everybody that
that he has hired in the white house a
good number of those individuals are
activists then you look at dhs itself
and the political appointees within dhs
it's permeated with ac with activists
and these are open border people these
are people that want
this to continue these are people that
want to bring more and more migrants
into the country that's the problem that
we face today is the political
appointees want to push back they want
the open borders they do not care about
what's happening right now
brandon thank you for being here with us
today this story is underway um as bill
milligan just said just overnight 900
got away so um we know that we know the
numbers that they counted coming in and
we know that there are now 900 that we
have no record of thank you so much for
being here hey everyone i'm emily
compagno catch me and my co-host harris
faulkner and kaylee mcinenneny on
outnumbered every weekday at 12 pm
eastern or set your dvr also don't
forget to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page for daily highlights